We get support from UC Davis, a globally ranked university, working to solve the world's most pressing problems in food, energy, health, education, and the environment. UC Davis researchers collaborate and innovate in California and around the globe to find transformational solutions. It's all part of the university's mission to promote quality of life for all living things. Find out more at 21centry.ucdavis.edu. This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. The details are not the details. They make the design. At John Edson, that's what he said.
我们得到了加州大学戴维斯分校的支持，这是一所全球知名的大学，致力于解决世界在食品、能源、健康、教育和环境方面最紧迫的问题。加州大学戴维斯分校的研究人员在加州及全球各地合作创新，以寻找变革性的解决方案。这完全符合该大学促进所有生物生活质量的使命。了解更多信息请访问 21centry.ucdavis.edu。这里是“99%隐形”。我是罗曼·马斯。细节不只是细节，细节造就了设计。约翰·埃森就是这么说的。
Quoting legendary designer Charles Eams. Express, test, and cycle. I'm John Edson, president of Lunar. Express, test, and cycle. There's a conception in the public, I think, that design is a lot about making things pretty. That's shifting, I think. There's a big DIY movement and maker movement, and people are getting a better sense of how things come to be. We've always known how kind of buildings came to be, because we'd watch them go up.
引用传奇设计师查尔斯·埃姆斯的语录。表达、测试、循环。我是约翰·埃森，Lunar公司的总裁。表达、测试和循环。我认为公众有一种观念，即设计在很大程度上就是把东西做得漂亮。我认为这种观念正在改变。现在有一个大型的DIY运动和创客运动，人们对事物是如何产生的有了更好的理解。我们一直都知道建筑物是如何建成的，因为我们可以看着它们拔地而起。
But products just kind of appear on the store shelf from somewhere, from China, right? But I really love the process of design and love bringing things to life, express, test, and cycle. The story that I want to tell about the details I wanted to product make is about a toothbrush. But there's a bit of a conflict of interest, or at least the perception of one,
但产品就像是从某个地方、从中国凭空出现在商店货架上，对吧？但我真的很喜欢设计的流程，喜欢将事物赋予生命：表达、测试、循环。我想讲述的关于产品细节的故事是一把牙刷。但这其中存在一点利益冲突，或者至少人们会这么认为，
that requires a disclaimer. So I asked Matt Martin to kalealeW to help me out. What matters to me, Roman, is that you are completely open about the fact that John Edson is the president of Bluner. Lunar underwrites these segments, but at the same time, you've got complete editorial control over how 99% of visible sounds. So what do you think you're going to say? Well, I'll think of something. You know what he said. This is the story of a toothbrush.
这就需要一个免责声明。所以我请KALW的马特·马丁来帮我一把。罗曼，对我来说最重要的是，你完全坦诚地表明约翰·埃森是Bluner的总裁。Lunar赞助了这些环节，但同时，你对99%隐形的声音拥有完全的编辑控制权。所以你觉得你会说什么？嗯，我会想出点说辞的。你知道他是怎么说的。这就是牙刷的故事。
Express. Expressing is getting a design out there in the world in a prototype form so that other people can look at it. And you can test it, you can evaluate it, and then you can decide what you're gonna do next. And cycle. And it really is this kind of forced evolutionary process. So the toothbrush company came to lunar
表达。表达是指以原型的形式将设计带入世界，以便其他人可以查看它。你可以对其进行测试、评估，然后决定下一步要做什么。循环。这确实是一种强迫的进化过程。所以牙刷公司找到Lunar
with what John Edson calls a make-pretty exercise. Make-pretty exercise. That's not really innovation. Our instinct was to ask them, well, how do people hold toothbrushes? But the toothbrush company didn't actually know this. So we engaged a hand-caneseologist. That's somebody who knows how people hold stuff.
提出了约翰·埃森所说的“美化”练习。“美化”练习。这算不上真正的创新。我们的直觉是问他们，人们究竟是怎么握牙刷的？但牙刷公司其实并不清楚这一点。于是我们聘请了一位手部运动机能学家。那是专门研究人们如何握持物品的人。
It turns out there are five common toothbrush grips. And in the meantime, our designers went out and bought every toothbrush under the sun. And we started to take the conventional flat toothbrush with brussels sticking up out of it. And we used a heat gun and made a bunch of different prototypes. We just bent.
事实证明，常见的牙刷握法有五种。与此同时，我们的设计师走出去，买下了天下所有的牙刷。我们开始拿传统的、刷毛直立的扁平牙刷，用热风枪制作了大量不同的原型。我们只是在弯曲它们。
Express. Those standard brushes into different shapes to see fundamentally what was working and what was not working. Test. Hundreds of sketches and dozens of prototypes. It's like one of the first things we found when we were molding our prototypes was that,
表达。将这些标准刷子塑造成不同的形状，从根本上找出什么管用，什么不管用。测试。数百张草图和几十个原型。这就像我们在制作原型时发现的第一批事情之一，
at the time, the reach toothbrush was probably best known as the most ergonomic toothbrush. This was all perception. It was only ergonomic in that it looked like a dental tool. And it was a dental tool that somebody else would use on you, the crook and the dental mirror. It's so that somebody can stick it in your mouth and manipulate it so they can see around your teeth. But the reach toothbrush, if you use it yourself, you end up with your hand back at your ear. So scrap the bend, straight handle is better.
在当时，Reach牙刷可能最为人所知的是最具人体工程学的牙刷。这完全是一种感知。它之所以符合人体工程学，仅仅是因为它看起来像一件牙科器械。那是别人会在你嘴里使用的牙科器械，带有弯头和牙医镜。那是为了让别人把它伸进你的嘴里并进行操作，以便他们能看清你的牙齿周围。但是Reach牙刷，如果你自己用它，你的手最终会退到耳边。所以取消弯曲，直手柄更好。
One of the things we found was a fatter toothbrush handle is more comfortable. So fat is better than thin, but at some point in the process, someone at the toothbrush company said, wait a minute, we can't ship a toothbrush that's got a fat handle on it like that, because it's not gonna fit into those 1950s style ceramic toothbrush holders that people have stuck to their walls
我们发现的一点是，更粗的牙刷手柄更舒适。所以粗柄比细柄好，但在流程的某个阶段，牙刷公司的一个人说，等一下，我们不能出货带有这种粗手柄的牙刷，因为它塞不进人们贴在墙上的那些20世纪50年代风格的陶瓷牙刷架里。
Part of their houses, right? But this turned out to be a good thing for the toothbrush malongers. They got a ton of press about it Oh, here's the toothbrush. It doesn't fit and Lunar came up with a strategy if anybody called to complain We created this little nickel-plated stand. They just send out this $5 component. Just like biological evolution, sure the organism adapts to the environment, but also the environment adapts to the organism. And now if you buy a toothbrush holder, it's going to have these gigantic holes in the top, right? So you can fit these new fangled toothbrushes in them.
他们房子的一部分，对吧？但事实证明这对牙刷制造商来说是件好事。他们因此获得了大量的媒体报道。哦，看这个牙刷。它塞不进去。Lunar想出了一个策略，如果有人打电话来投诉，我们就制作了这个小型的镀镍支架。他们只需寄出这个5美元的组件。就像生物进化一样，当然生物会适应环境，但环境也会适应生物。现在，如果你买一个牙刷架，它的顶部会有这些巨大的洞，对吧？这样你就能把这些新式牙刷插进去了。
Future-oriented. In addition to the straight and fat handles, the new toothbrush also had criss-cross bristles. Angled bristles. That was brand new. The handle was strategically flattened in parts to help you orient it. Your fingers know which way the bristles are pointed in your mouth. And it accommodated all of the five brushing grips identified by the kinesiologist. There's a spoon grip.
面向未来。除了直且粗的手柄外，新牙刷还采用了交叉刷毛。倾斜的刷毛。这是全新的。手柄在某些部位经过了策略性的扁平化处理，以帮助你辨别方向。你的手指知道刷毛在你的嘴里指向哪个方向。它适应了运动机能学家确定的五种刷牙握法中的每一种。其中有一种是勺式握法。
There's the death grip. More women than men use the death grip. When I asked John Etzen which was his favorite innovation in the toothbrush, he named something that most people will consider a lack of design or innovation, just getting the toothbrush back to having a straight handle. It's not trying to do anything crazy through the neck. That's the best shape, really. You know, those kind of, duh, innovations.
还有死亡之握。使用死亡之握的女性比男性多。当我问约翰·埃森他最喜欢牙刷的哪项创新时，他提到了大多数人会认为是缺乏设计或创新的东西——仅仅让牙刷恢复直柄。它没有试图在颈部做任何疯狂的设计。这真的是最好的形状。你知道，那些显而易见的创新。
And that's a big part of design. The thing you don't think about or notice notice probably had the most thought put into it. 99% Invisible is produced by me Roman Mars with support from Lunar. It's a project of KALW, the American Institute of Architects, San Francisco, and the Center for Architecture and Design. Find out more at 99%invisible.org. visit bold.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这也是设计的重要一部分。那些你没有想到或注意到的东西，可能投入的心思最多。《99%隐形》由我罗曼·马斯制作，Lunar提供支持。这是KALW、美国建筑师协会旧金山分会以及建筑与设计中心的一个项目。了解更多信息请访问 99%invisible.org。访问 bold.org。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。